so if our goal is to get mothers to
choose baby formula over their own
breast milk all we gotta do is to get
their doctors to tell them to so you
start Nestle's 1970s influencer campaign
to basically get doctors to say formula
good breast milk bad
you pay doctors and nurses to suggest
your formula as an alternative to breast
milk and in places like Asia and Africa
you even hire sales women dress them up
like nurses and get them to hand out
free samples and medical advice and you
make sure that these free samples are
just big enough that by the time they
run out these mothers would have stopped
making breast milk naturally cementing a
profitable loyal customer